neben der impfpflicht ein thema was dich
besonders beschäftigt hat auch in den
vergangenen tagen immer wieder zwei g2
gipfel ja und da hast du die schafe
meinung mitgebracht jedes beschäftigt
mich ja seit der einführung muss sich
jetzt wirklich mal sagen ich finde es
gibt nichts schlimmeres eigentlich mit
aktuell als zweig in deutschland ich
finde es furchtbar
wir grenzen menschen aus und es erklärt
sich mir die sinnhaftigkeit nicht also
das ist eigentlich für mich aktuell das
schlimmste ich verstehe die regelung
nicht einmal mehr als zum beispiel wer
silvester da sind auch bekannte von mir
aber man hat ja generell auch die fotos
gesehen in den skiurlaub gefahren haben
schön party gemacht sich ein rein
getrunken und was war am ende kam alle
mit krone nach hause das heißt die
geburtsdaten dürfen feiern dürfen
zusammen im club sitzen aber menschen
die sich gegen die impfung persönlich
entschieden haben dürfen nicht mals für
ihre kinder und jetzt muss ich auch mal
emotional werden weil die die immer für
alles argumentieren argumentieren ja
auch immer mit den kindern war ich jetzt
auch mal dürfen nicht mehr als für ihre
kinder schulutensilien kaufen die dürfen
nicht mal für ihre kinder eine mütze
kaufen wenn sie die verlieren das tun
kinder übrigens öfter die muss jetzt
online bestellt werden und das ist für
mich ein absoluter wahnsinn
und ich frage mich wie wir als land das
weiter mitmachen wollen zweig ich frage
mich wie politiker weiter in den spiegel
schauen können die das zu verantworten
haben und dementsprechend ist mein
appell ganz klar einführung von 3g
flächendeckend und zwar so vor sofort
zweige plus ist übrigens jedoch absurd
da womit fange ich jetzt gar nicht erst
an wenn ich finde vor allem ein aspekt
beunruhigend muss ich sagen nämlich die
frage was das eine mit unserer
wirtschaft macht ich habe viele freunde
restaurant dichtmachen mussten ihre bar
dichtmachen mussten ihr geschäft
dichtmachen mussten weil das alles so
nicht mehr funktioniert und ist ja nicht
nur das eine sondern es gibt die omikron
welle wo alle in quarantäne müssen
obwohl ich kann es ja aus eigener
erfahrung berichten dass wirklich nur
ein leichter schnupfen ist und in
anderen ländern man nach wenigen tagen
wieder raus darf aber in deutschland da
haben wir unsere festen regeln und da
darf keiner raus zuvorderst nicht
irgendwie wie auch immer frei getestet
wurde so und das ist das eine das trifft
die geschäfte wahnsinnig hat die
einzelhändler all das was und wie daraus
mache absolut jetzt immer noch die
plexiglasscheiben und dass sie alles
machen mussten um öffnen zu dürfen das
ist aber jetzt auch wieder irrelevant
was sie aufgebaut haben der größte witz
wenn ich das noch sagen hab ich hab mich
fürchterlich aufgeregt am samstag in
düsseldorf ich war draußen essen was
hier selten hinaus drückt und wir sagen
sogar draußen unter den heizstrahlern
weil die haben die alle aufgebaut in dem
auch noch außengastronomie zu schaffen
mehr platz und dann fragt mich der
kellner nach meinem haus war es dann
habe ich ihn vor gezahlt weil er gesagt
ich muss noch sehen dass es drei von
drei ist sozusagen das kann ich ihnen
auch gerne zeigen ich bin ja gewusst
aber ich möchte sie jetzt ganz ehrlich
mal fragt wozu denn ich sitze hier
draußen an der frischen luft der nächste
tisches ein meter entfernt mit meinen
beiden freundinnen und eine freundin von
uns die hätte dann auch gar nicht mehr
dazu kommen können wir alle schnell
testmöglichkeiten also doppelt geben
konnten keinen schnelltest mehr machen
draußen in der außengastronomie muss ich
mich auch gerne einmal frau war ich
wieder mehr hinnehmen
sie haben versuche hört
macht das alles noch irgendwie sinn und
gibt es da noch eine logik in der
politik was corona angeht also ich
glaube epidemiologisch hat zweig noch
nie sinn gemacht also zunächst wurde das
ja so begründet dass angeblich die
ungeimpften die großen viren schleudern
sind und deswegen draußen bleiben müssen
und wir wissen heute dass das begründet
wurde teilweise mit zahlen die wirklich
verfälscht waren also das waren ja die
berühmten in sidenten von herrn söder
und der center
sozusagen alle
infektionen wo man den impfstatus nicht
kannte den mit denen umgehen
hinzugerechnet hatte hatte man
astronomische intelligenzen unter um
games noch besser wir müssen jetzt
überall draußen bleiben inzwischen weiß
man geimpfte selbst gebuchte jeder kann
sich anstecken jeder kann auch andere
anstecken baumkronen gibt es da
überhaupt keinen unterschied mehr also
es eher so dass doppelt geimpfte sich
sogar öfter anstecken und gehe jetzt hat
man eine neue begründung jetzt sagt man
ja man muss die ungewissen quasi vor
sich selber schützen also dass sie sich
nicht anstecken bei den anderen deswegen
müssen sie draußen bleiben also das ist
so fadenscheinig und da finde ich hat
makro also der französische präsident
war in dem punkt zwar noch ehrlicher der
hat der zweig eingeführt mit der
begründung er will die ungeimpften
schikanieren hat er ganz klar gesagt er
will die ungeimpften schikanieren damit
die endlich sich impfen lassen und dann
muss ich sagen das war zumindest eine
ehrliche ansage so sind ich noch besser
als die heuchelei die dann immer
irgendwelche begründungen vorschiebt die
einfach nicht stimmen aber natürlich ist
es nicht verfassungsgemäß menschen zu
schikanieren weil sie ein recht
wahrnehmen und noch gibt es in
deutschland so wie eben auch in
frankreich gar keine impfpflicht für
alle und deswegen finde ich also zweig
geht überhaupt nicht ich bekomme auch
wirklich ganz viele mails von leuten die
mir tragische situation schreiben als
sie können nicht mehr mit ihren kindern
ins schwimmbad können ihr kind irgendwo
anders nicht hin begleiten jugendliche
können nicht mehr im sport club
trainieren obwohl dass sie ihre
gesundheit wichtig ist nur weil sie eben
noch nicht geimpft sind oder sich auch
dagegen entschieden haben also das ist
alles absurd und ich hoffe mal dass das
irgendwann ein ende hat ja und ich weiß
was ich will
und jetzt wird so getan als könne man
sich all diese probleme entledigen wenn
man nur diese verdammten impfpflicht
zustimmt das argument habe ich heute im
bundestag ungefähr 20 mal gehört also
das gegengeschäft lautet alle maßnahmen
weg dieser ganze quatsch und unsinn weg
musste der halt nur die spritze setzen
lassen jetzt muss man sich immer
vorstellt ich denke mir auch oft würden
vor zwei jahren sozusagen
prognostiziert hätten dass in unserem
land so was geschieht dann hätten uns
die leute für verrückt halten das wäre
selbst für einen science fiction roman
zu viel gewesen wäre hätte man nicht
verkauft kurzfristig musste mal ich muss
mal massiv ihr widersprechen doch gerade
was franken nicht gesagt hat weil aber
ich habe eben eine frage stellen wir
gerne ja diese haben sie schikaniert mit
ihrer partei bei den regeln and also
dass die regel natürlich extrem hart
waren und auch wirklich diese grund und
freiheit einschränken alles andere als
leicht sind ist doch klar ich gehöre
übrigens auch immer zu denjenigen die
gesagt haben wir dürfen diese grund und
freiheitsrechten nicht zum dauerzustand
machen und ich habe genauso wie es herr
strunz eben auch formuliert hat immer
wieder darauf hingewiesen dass viele
maßnahmen nicht zielgenau sind also zum
beispiel in hamburg haben wir erlebt
dass spd und grünen den masken pflicht
für jogger verhängt haben also andere
als da draußen mit maske zum wochenende
ist natürlich idiotisch und
viele regeln kann man nicht
nachvollziehen noch mal ein beispiel aus
hamburg die elbphilharmonie ist drinnen
gefüllt dass die leute dicht gedrängt
zusammen und ein fußballstadion was
draußen ist fünf und fünfzehn 60.000
zuschauer umfasst da dürfen dann
irgendwie 2000 leute sich ein derby hsv
gegen pauli anschauen das kann man nicht
nachvollziehen deswegen da muss man
immer wieder den finger in die wunde
legen nur was auch völlig fatal ist und
den eindruck hat jetzt frau wagenknecht
hier erweckt es ist als ob es völlig
egal sei ob man sich impfen lässt oder
nicht und das zeigen ja nun wirklich
alle studien dass die impfquote schon
sehr sehr wichtig ist da in bezug auf
den zustand der intensivstation des
gesundheitswesens aber auch damit
natürlich das virus sich nicht
ausbreitet und wir dann immer zur
einschränkung zur frage ob dann zwar
gerechtfertigt ist naja zweig führt
natürlich einerseits dazu dass
diejenigen die dann geimpft sind die
auch geschützt sind dass die sich dass
die sich relativ sicher sein können und
zumindest sicherer dass sie nicht
angesteckt werden und sicher hat dass
sie nicht auf der intensivstation danach
sollen alle studien beim lesen nicht
vermeiden gab mich wieder angestellt hat
nun ist er hätte zweig nicht jahre ja
wann zahlen natürlich gibt es immer
durch brüder und wir wissen glaubt
monika und gibt es auch relativ viel
wasser und lava aber wir wissen auch
dass natürlich die geimpften viel
bessere verläuft haben im schnitt in
silber für läufer gerade haben sie haben
einmal seiner lage bei den immer soll
das sollte also es ist ja völlig angriff
einige unterschiedliche dinge also
geimpft haben natürlich ein viel
geringeres risiko an koronaren und wenn
sie erkranken sind impft durchbruch gibt
dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit viel
geringer dass sie auf der
intensivstation landen so dass er
einfach nicht die leute sind besser
geschützt und das sorgt am ende
natürlich auch dafür dass das
gesundheitswesen
dass die intensivstation nicht
überlastet werden wenn die impfquote
hoch ist wenn je niedriger sie ist desto
höher ist die gefahr einer überlastung
und natürlich auch eine verbreitung des
virus und ich glaube wir sagen wie lange
reichen lang applaus deswegen ist schon
wichtig dass wir an der hohen impfquoten
arbeiten frau bank nicht wie lange
den eindruck als ob das völlig egal wie
lange noch im allgemeinen wie lang
eindruck ich weiß es nicht ich
glaube dass also das hängt jetzt sehe
ich will gar nicht spekulieren weil ich
es wirklich nicht weiß wenn wir
tatsächlich dass wir jetzt das beste
szenario in bald in der endemischen lage
kommen corona sich zur so eine art
schnupfen entwickelt dann können wir
zweig sehr schnell abschaffen sodann
kann sagen wir ein paar wochen schon
sagen wir leben wieder so weitestgehend
wie vorher wenn es aber mutanten gibt
dann kann es natürlich sein dass wir
werden uns aber vielleicht noch jahre
das weiß das weiß kann es gibt ja schon
zumuten so und er und gibt ja schon
viele kommunen die sagen es gibt die
möglichkeit dass ungarn das in die
endemische lager geführt aber ich weiß
es nicht sagen was wo es wichtig ist
dass ich vorher sage ich bin doppelt
geimpft wird bunt gemustert aber wie
wäre es denn wenn man sich überlegen
würde wie man es zu hausregeln würde
also wenn ich ein essen geben würde für
zehn leute wer mir nur ein einziges g
wichtig nämlich getestet heute ja die
leute ob meine gäste sicher impfen haben
lassen und meine gäste genesen sind weil
sie krank waren ob meine gäste sich
nicht in die hessen wollen weil sie
vielleicht bei youtube aber klaus da
kommt so was das problem ist dass test
ja nicht hinter deutschland ja nur den
gedanken einmal nur ich weiß ja dass er
irgendwie weit von der eleganz aber alle
reden über 3g und 2g westen mit eingehe
und dann aber dafür tests an jeder ecke
also wie kaugummi kauen da müssen wir
uns natürlich fast 100 prozent sicher
sein was ist denn immer 100 prozent mein
lieber die straße laufen
einen punkt machen ganz kurz zuvor war
ich weil sie kann er nicht mit sitzen
sondern ist uns dazu geschadet ich würde
ihn gern noch an ihre meinungen und das
nicht einfach so stehen lassen und zwar
dass sie den eindruck erweckt hat das
impfen gar nichts bringt so habe ich sie
noch nie verstanden vielleicht will frau
wann kann ich dazu nur die rückantwort
sagen weil ich kann ja nicht dann sollte
aber bitte aussagen wie sie die
impfquote verbessern möchte weil das das
mit aufklärung und werbung nicht so
zufriedenstellend läuft wie man es
bräuchte das haben wir ja gesehen dass
wir sagen nicht an bord
die impfquote verbessern oder muss die
aus ihrer sicht überhaupt verbessert
werden ja also erstmal bin ich dankbar
dass ich jetzt noch mal rein kommen weil
ich glaube wirklich dass ich mich gern
so stehen lassen würde natürlich weiß
man dass die impfungen vor schweren
verläufen schützt oder zumindest die
wahrscheinlichkeit mit einem schweren
verlauf konfrontiert zu sein deutlich
verringert der schutz ist zeitlich
begrenzt also denn lässt nach wenn die
impfung einen monat zurückliegt aber er
ist erst mal ein ganz wichtiger fakt und
deswegen habe ich dafür dass ältere
menschen sich impfen lassen ohne jede
frage und wer als junger moment sich
also das ist ein risiko so abwegig dass
er sagt ich habe mehr angst vor der
erkrankung der sollte sich auch impfen
lassen ich bin ja nur dafür dass es
jeder für sich entscheiden kann also ich
bin nicht jemand der jetzt auch in
gottes willen man soll sich nicht impfen
lassen also das wäre ja völlig
bescheuert und gerade bei älteren leuten
wäre es verantwortungslos so was zu
erzählen aber was hat sie im futter
angeht wie gesagt ich hab ja vorhin
schon darauf hingewiesen also ein
deutsches problem in corona ist dass wir
eigentlich so gar nicht irgendwie
verlässliche daten haben noch nicht mal
zur impfquote offiziell ist jetzt 73 das
lka hat wahrscheinlich selbst fünf
prozentpunkte mehr und dann werden wir
bei 78 prozent
da sind wir unter den fünf ländern in
europa mit den höchsten im boden also
wir stehen dann ein fünfter stelle alle
anderen haben weniger und trotzdem
diskutieren die meisten länder nicht
über eine allgemeine impfpflicht also
wir sind gar nicht so schlecht wenn man
jetzt mal gut und schlecht mit mit der
höhe der inflation setzen will wie das
immer dargestellt wird wir haben eine
wahrscheinlich also relativ gute
impfquote wir haben vor allem bei den
älteren das hatte ich ja vorhin gesagt
nimm quote von rund 93 prozent bei den
über 60-jährigen und wir haben jetzt vor
allem auch ganz viele die eben mit dem
virus in kontakt kommen sich war sie
natürlich postern weil sie einfach ja
eine infektion bekommen und ich fand
interessant dass die amerikanische
gesundheitsbehörde jetzt noch mal gesagt
hat uns ganz im gegensatz zu herrn
lauterbach weg für entscheidungen vor
kurzem die haben gesagt denke die
genesenen sind deutlich längerfristig
gegen schwere verläufe geschützt als die
geimpften und da sollte man auch mal zur
kenntnis nehmen das heißt wenn jetzt
sehr viele menschen auch gerade wenn sie
vorher geimpft sind in den risikogruppen
ist es ja gut wenn sie vorher geimpft
sind aber wenn sie dann jetzt mit dem
virus in kontakt kommen dann haben sie
quasi bauen sie einen immunschutz auch
ist die hoffnung habe dass er dann auch
im winter weiter hält